testing 1 2 this is not a drill
Illuma and madonna dropped their music
video for Medellin and there's one scene
that cannot be unseen found myself
dancing in the rain yeah that's
absolutely Madge licking the Lumas big
toe and here at ET we think it's
important to show it on a loop to let it
really sink it found myself dancing in
the rain found myself dancing in the
rain found myself dancing in the rain I
[Music]
just wanted to do something different
there are nods to Madonna's iconic past
the Catholic confessional the wedding
dress and sexuality boozing everywhere
[Music]
feels so natural this is my year and
maluma is on brand as ever the Colombian
heartthrob shows off his cha-cha skills
smokes and drinks in bed that even
smooches his bride smack on the lips we
like to think of it as a subtle homage
to this colliding with the Queen of Pop
was a huge bucket list moment for the 25
year old singer he broke down in tears
after hearing the song for the first
time 2018 maluma told ET he had big
dreams of crossing over to the English
market for things that you want to
accomplish this year another huge
American collaborations I think that
will be a huge moment for their land
industry and American industry and we
know this ladies man is all about female
empowerment man without women we're
nothing you're gonna see something very
important my my show my performance I'm
gonna be surrounded of a woman but
you're gonna see you're gonna love it I
have a big surprise for you
and it's like showing the dagger power
[Music]